I think the part about Trump that is his  challenge here's the challenge he's got  my opinion I could be wrong but I think  he wants to fight everybody and 99 of  people are now worth fighting and it's  just kind of like what'd you say what'd  you say like like you know you go to the  club with the one friend and he just  what'd you look at me for what what he's  that guy so Worst Guys  what he just tried to do today he's  trying to fight it too much 99 of the  fights at the club Listen People gonna  bump into you at the club yes if you if  Future Would You Do it's like dude it's  a tight spot people don't bump into each  other just kind of walk through she oh  you almost have to tell them when we  make it to the bar which is only 20  yards away about nine people are going  to bump into you they're not trying to  fight you they're gonna bump into you  it's okay I think that's his deal